يعني حاليا نحن نتحدث عن تنفيذ عمليه
جديده والان تحديدا في حيث سلوان هناك
استنفار كبير للقوات الاسرائيليه في
المنطقه ايضا اغلاق مداخل حي سلوان بالقدس
هناك ايضا اصابتين بعمليه اطلاق نار نفذها
فلسطيني في المنطقه وهناك ايضا انباء عن
ارتقاء منفذ العمليه في سلوان قبل قليل
نحن نتحدث عن عن هذه العمليه هي عمليه
خطيره وخطيره جدا بسبب وجودها في موقع
حساس وهو ايضا قريب على مداخل المسجد
الاقصى المبارك نحن نتحدث عن يعني استنفار
ايضا في الشوارع همم هنا في القدس ايضا
يعني اردنا ان نتحدث عن مفتش الشرطه العام
ايضا قال واعلن عن استنفار قبل قليل ورفع
حاله التاهب لدرجه القصوى ليس فقط في
القسوه وانما ايضا في الضفه الغربيه
والجميع همم
وجميع البلاد